I'm gonna count the amount of times I
say bad ass in this review it's pretty
badass tombstone not to be mistaken with
Wyatt Earp with Kevin Costner same basic
story as tombstone three times as long
and about a hundred times more boring
than another movie that's more boring
than tombstone now for me Tim stones one
of my favorite westerns because it's a
perfect mix of realistic yet fun and
even badass now in Tombstone Wyatt Earp
and his brothers arrived in Tombstone
with no interest in being the law or
anything like that they just want to
retire make some money live happy but
the douchebag Cowboys are in town led by
curly bill played by the vice president
from 24 one of them anyway Michael Biehn
aka corporal Hicks from aliens and their
Lackey Ike Clanton aka the douchebag
from Avatar and with both parties in
town you know friction and okay corral
shootouts now you already know that this
movie's gonna have some bad AI shootouts
what you might not know is before Johnny
Depp was Jack Sparrow Val Kilmer was Doc
Holliday I only say that because as Jack
Sparrow is the man in Pirates of the
Caribbean
Doc Holliday is the man in Tombstone I
mean he's sarcastic funny badass a
ladies man even though he's half-dead
from tuberculosis in the movie he is the
character that all guys want to be when
we watch these movies
yeah Doc Holliday no disrespect to Wyatt
Earp in the straight arrow Funky Bunch
or anything like that it's just that
Doc Holliday is badass in all ways that
we find badass badass that's right kids
if your teacher tells you you shouldn't
want to beat someone else you should be
happy with who you are she clearly did
not watch tombstone and actually thought
all the characters were played really
well the one that's least memorable Bill
Paxton somehow he gets overshadowed by
Sam Elliott's mustache Oh game over man
game overs red dude I just really like
the premise of ordinary people standing
up against the douchebags they may turn
a blind eye for as long as they can but
eventually they're gonna stand up to
them cuz that's just what needs to
happen so this is definitely a Western
that I think most people can enjoy if
you like True Grit you will like
Tombstone if you didn't like True Grit
you will like tombstone it has great
lines I still quote this movie to this
day well I have not yet begun to defile
myself
Doc Holliday man bad ass I'm not sure
what rating I should give a movie that's
been out for almost 20 years so I will
call it a Western classic
[Applause]
per Jeremy Johnson is it historically
accurate to what really happened in
Tombstone I don't know I didn't go for
the history lesson
I watched it to watch an awesome Western
badass Western check it out if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more than click right here to see
more
[Music]